hello oh my god wait what why is
everything different hey calm down
it's all right don't worry so I may have
changed a few things without asking your
permission before I changed them behave
I mean it's not like a need your
permission to change things up a little
bit I mean you're not my mom
unless of course you are my mum in which
case hello mum how you doing so the
first change that I need to mention
which is by the way by far the most
important change that has occurred is
the fact that I've got a new camera to
give you comparison actually this is my
old camera so this is what this looks
like
hello we have fun here at charlie is so
cool like don'twe very interested my old
camera is a sony HDR sr 10 and my new
camera this is AK and 60d with a big
lens thing and a rode videomic for sound
essentially I paid about two thousand
pounds so that I can have a slightly
blurrier background I'll leave it up to
you about whether or not you think that
was worth it another feature I like
about this camera actually is that I can
now be available in wide-angle Wow
well you look at that look it look at
that Wow from here you can see bit more
of background a bit more of me and
that's it so again worth the money I can
do this which is a lot of fun for me
might not be fun for you but I'm
enjoying it the other change that I've
made which is by the way vastly less
important you know hardly important at
all really is the fact that I might have
cut off all of my red hair for those
among you who are out of the loop about
eight months ago I dyed my hair bright
red because I was challenged to and also
just because I thought it'd be fun but I
kind of wasn't thinking about the fact
that when you dye your hair red with
permanent hair dye it kind of stays red
permanently I'm not really want to
particularly care about looks I mean you
can see here today zit zit still making
a video but in my last two videos I wore
a hat to cover up my hair because it
just looks so frickin stupid and also to
be honest my self-esteem was taking a
knock because people kept on calling me
Ron Weasley so I came to the conclusion
that the only way to escape was to chop
it all off and I'm quite happy with it
honestly I think I look a bit David
Tennant ish with this dude I got some
messages from people saying that they
saw my new hair and started to cry which
is you know in my opinion probably a bit
of an overreaction however for those
among you who are
the red hair I've decided to put aside
some time to make this little tribute so
here we go roll VT Charlie's red hair oh
how we miss you now you're not there
you're in the bin but you'll always grow
within my heart
now we're apart you make me start to cry
my eyes out but don't depart you know I
can though I don't know why because
you're just hair
goodbye Charlie's red hair you'll always
have a special place in our hearts see
what I did your video edited because
that or good so I seem to have made a
video all about hair and cameras today
so sorry about that I guess right bye
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool hello